well it gets crazier there's a piece
it's a true
truly magnificent work of journalism
from the la times
with a naked woman sitting spread eagle
on the asphalt
in portland she's one of these rioters
sitting completely naked and the
headline is out of portland tear gas
an apparition emerges capturing the
imagination of protesters
some people have tweeted they said oh
you know that's pretty nice get to see a
naked lady
i don't know if you guys have ever met
antifa if you've ever seen them up close
i have they're not like the most
hygienic people on earth okay they're
not they tend not to be
supermodels so i think we can only see
this woman from the back but i don't
i i i don't envy the cops who have to
look at this
listen to the headline listen to the
article rather
she emerged as an apparition from clouds
of tear gas
as federal agents fired pepper balls at
angry protesters
in early saturday darkness wow am i
reading like a
reading like a romance novel or
something like that a woman wearing
nothing but a black face mask
and a stocking cap strode toward a dozen
heavily armed agents attired
in camouflage fatigues lined up across a
downtown street
the agents dispatched by the trump
administration over
vociferous objections of state and city
officials
are part of a force that has fired
projectiles at
and detained activists protesting
nightly
since the killing of george floyd by
minneapolis police may 25th
let me i'll translate that to you into
english rioters have burned down cities
and attacked people and in instances
killed people and so the cops are now
arresting them
that's it that's you could have i was
that one sentence it was one sentence
that's what's actually happening here
numerous photos and videos posted to
twitter show the unidentified woman as
she halted in the middle of the street
at 1 45 am
she stood calmly a surreal image of
human vulnerability
in the face of an overpowering force
that has been criticized
nationally by civil rights advocates oh
has it
it has been critic the cops have been
criticized
by oh by the la times right for
arresting
rioters okay the thing goes on i mean i
can't
before it was over she struck ballet
poses and reclined on the street
she also sat on the asphalt in a
yoga-like position
facing the officers before they left
wow that is that is a poetic journey it
reminds me of
uh kennedy's supreme court decision in
obergefell which read less like law and
more like romantic poetry that reads
less like journalism
more like romantic poetry imagine
imagine that kind of talk
how about how about we just arrest
rioters and people who are
engaged in public indecency like sitting
spread eagle on the asphalt in front of
cops
that's not going to happen that is not
going to happen
at all what we are in the midst of
is a a narrative we are living in a
narrative
that it we are told is the truth it's
not just political truth it's scientific
truth
rioter is good cops bad burning down the
country good building it back up bad
george washington
very very bad leftist marxist
activists very very good we're told this
is
eternally true science if you disagree
with it
not only are you wicked but you're crazy
or insane you probably have to be sent
to an insane asylum and we lionize the
politicians who pretend to be doctors
who pretend to be scientists who push
this ridiculous agenda and lie to our
faces
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full episode linked in the
description
or download the podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
you